initially carlos barrocal thought he and
his mother would leave quietly as his
neighbors had
for 25 years they've called this four
bedroom flat in barcelona home
then he realized finding another
apartment anywhere in the city for the
six hundred eighty five dollars a month
they've been paying is impossible
he's been fighting eviction for the past
four years ami
police are expected to forcibly remove
him and his mother from the apartment
the week of christmas
this is affecting me emotionally i'm my
mother even more
i've had to distance her from all of
this struggle because of her illness but
it's impossible to do that completely
throughout the eu the average supply of
affordable housing is nine percent in
spain it's just two and a half percent
according to government data in the last
20 years the rental market has only
grown because of a lack of jobs and low
wages the brookings institution
estimates the government needs to
provide at least one and a half million
rental homes to low-income earners
the catalonia region which includes
barcelona implemented a rent control
policy last year the first in spain the
conservative popular party is now
challenging it in court
the city is in the process of building 8
000 affordable rental homes and forging
public-private partnerships to build
more
we have to bear in mind that 40 of
people in barcelona are renting let's
think about young people who have normal
jobs and can't afford to pay market
price housing so it's a structural
problem and doesn't affect only a
specific sector of the population
the tenants union of catalonia says
decades of failing to provide affordable
housing has altered spanish society
i think it is mostly breaking
relationships in neighborhoods and
and cities and towns because we
we argued that the right to housing is
not only to have a shelter but also to
have a neighborhood to have a community
to be part of
instead of christmas decorations at the
berocal's home moving boxes are at the
ready but after contacting the un
commission for human rights carlos is
feeling hopeful
the u.n is asking the government to
suspend eviction or offer him and his
mother alternative housing while the
case is reviewed
natasha name al jazeera barcelona